L fer failed clear Carlo geeky a knockdown
tip laier back to gustaffson a tip by tro
our laier shck Kirk intercepts the clear
po that's a good idea little takeaway got
bothered a little bit but the best shift of
the period by Boston Carlos Drive sticks in
sherin's gut go to Anaheim then they scored
the other five Pak a shot that had Chinese
mustard on it panan oh sing a great save
panan laier swming aggressive off his
line gives it away to water spoon Van
rekes Hammer shot ptra with stking way
out of his net Barlo waves it Fox closes
the shot sticks in Jeremy Swan's Lo year to Fox
panan to Linden a r shot and a saveing close on
laughr troch Swan had it broken
down paner to Fox and tipped by
cder and it comes right back
to him off glast and Swan is
calm Z jum to crer a kick save and a beauty by San
ja KK Maran swivels it van re dke a
shot Point Blank that just jerking
saves um what do you think uh about the number
and all that stuff I'm like well you know I I
really I really don't feel comfortable keeping
the number wearing a number I should never have
been given the number in the first place cuz
when I came to Boston you know people asked
me about wearing that number about it being
retired someday and I always said that he was
an amazing Legend and everything that Phil
did here that of course the number deserves
to be retired so uh 1:00 that afternoon uh we
came to a decision that I was going to go out
for warmup with number seven come back in and
go in the trainer's room and uh put number 77
under uh number seven and then we're going to
call Phil up and reveal number 77 and the way
it worked out was just an amazing amazing here
we go Frank frerick can I call that one perfect
go you can take my job anytime rck and I would
make a pretty good T what you [Applause] think
well we got a look at this off the rush
nice little backand dish padro continues
on usually linear hockey is not the way you
want to attack but that's the way the play
velop and Van re just trying to get it to
the blue paint Frederick goes hard to the
net so what he was having he couldn't
figure anything out on the menu um and
it was just fun it's you know believe me
you know I'm chairing for the other team
at that time uh and it's I mean I you know
we had the better hand most times pin to Fox
krider and grizzli got a
stick beater exhibition game against Philadelphia
in Providence I just remember John Winston get in
the fight and I you know back then you drop
your gloves you're hanging on to somebody and
you're just real close to the fight you got to
show them that you have their back and you know
people don't realize that you know I've got
probably about 20 fights in my career Patra
attacking the puck linski closes and a kick save
and no rebound by San off poock Skate warai One
Touch to poock Flips it off the blocker up
the boards Adam Fox walks the Blue Line San
no rebound curs back out of the fox pin a
save by San the Bruins on a brief power play
Schneider and a save by swan
ostock
gets it back from chatton Kirk and a save
by shurkin slap pass by sabana J the long
change Jake tbros on the island and San
Alexis laier Miller to Wheeler around the
perimeter wher's one timer yeah you've
done a great job killing that penalty
keeping the lead a kick Sav and another by
swimming yeah now take care of business get
out of your own Zone lorai up the boards
not clear but POA on a oneman [Applause]
rush DeAndre Miller a blocker stopped by
Swan Dan reik hand pass legally frerick
TOA he gets buried by
trouba Co tried to Center Pak
takes a [Applause] run 10 seconds
left Ryder has shooting on his mind and does wide
trouba clean entry Chris cder
saved by San robbing Vincent
troch deep for prder prder slips it into
the slot sometimes you just go down and
you get a penalty call Carlo with a
very little push from behind on a pu
was headed in the directional a friend
GE Che scores that's a gift that's a
gift and Maron draws a tripping call then he has
possession of the puck on the five on four gets
tripped again and they let it go opportunities
and it's a Well executed play they got tons of
talent it's a simple little give and goal two-man
cycle game great shot little [Applause] blocker
G Thro Che takes it back to Center
Ice Pon to troch he
scores the Rangers win in overtime
2 to one the Bruins go almost three
cross defensively and troch after he makes
the pass he just drifts in makes himself
available for a one-time below the dot paner
finds him with a perfect pass two- one time
this Puck some confusion as to who has who
everybody looking at the puck car paner game
over this is the second time in three games
that the Bruins have had the
lead into the third period and